por lo general ser humano desde los
comienzos siempre sabemos que era innato
que tenía que contar que tenía que
contar historias todo lo que fue la
literatura el teatro la música hasta que
llegó la invención digamos de la
tecnología que lo primero el gran
impacto fue todo el tema de la imprenta
que una revolución una democratización
en el acceso a los contenidos o bien
digamos otro desarrollo mucho más
avanzado que es el desarrollo del cine
que podríamos decir que no solamente fue
una un desarrollo como expresión
artística sino como industria de los
contenidos
llegamos un momento además donde tuvimos
grandes movimientos en europa hollywood
etcétera etcétera pero fue digamos
nuestra primera industria cultural
luego tenemos digamos la importancia que
tuvo lo audiovisual en la representación
de nuestra identidad de dónde vienen
digamos por si ustedes se acuerdan las
fiestas con las rancheras que teníamos
en los grados de los colegios etcétera
etcétera eso se da básicamente por el
cine mexicano una televisión que
reflejado de alguna manera es sentir el
folklore las tradiciones de cada uno de
cada una de las regiones
tenemos azúcar que está margarita si mal
no recuerdan caballo viejo por supuesto
entonces fueron digamos la televisión
fue la que realmente a nosotros nos
ayudó a construir como nación
ya generar una identidad
resulta que viene otro momento muy
importante y es el cambio en las
audiencias y como perciben las
audiencias los contenidos veníamos de
una son gracias pasivas que simplemente
se sentaban en la televisión veía en la
televisión pasivamente o el cine
pasivamente ahora son sobre todo
interactivas generaciones y además están
con todo el tema de juegos con realidad
virtual etcétera etcétera pero hay
especialmente una empresa que marca el
consumo el surgimiento de netflix
acuérdense que nosotros antes
alquilábamos teníamos los alquileres de
vídeos la gente quería ver las series de
una vez en cualquier momento en
cualquier lugar y era cuando uno
alquilaba todo el paquete completo o
vendían el paquete completo y ellos lo
que traduce en esto se convierten de una
empresa de alquiler de videos
un servicio de streaming esto no
solamente cambió ese modelo también
cambió el modelo en la realización
cinematográfica los canales empiezan a
adoptar un lenguaje cinematográfico
empiezan también digamos a hacer casi
que un largometraje dividido en
diferentes porque además ya lo tenemos
el tema de la televisión que tiene que
ser 25 minutos o 50 minutos sino que yo
de alguna manera sus directores pensaban
en un largometraje dividido en
diferentes capítulos entonces eso cambia
totalmente la manera de cómo la gente
consumía
los contenidos entonces aquí hay un tema
muy importante y es que la gente vendía
tiene el control el niño el usuario
tienen el control de qué es lo que
quieren ver por dónde navegan el
contenido a nosotros con una generación
que estábamos acostumbrados a dos o tres
canales y nada más y era lo único que
teníamos para ver hoy en día
estos niños voy a bajar el volumen de
pronto yo hoy en día estos niños que
cada vez son más interactivos son cada
vez digamos están consumiendo hay un
grave problema es que no sabemos lo que
están consumiendo muchas veces hace poco
leía una encuesta en argentina donde los
padres no sabían generalmente el 70% de
los niños encuestados no saben que
estaban viendo los sus padres no sabían
que lo que estaban viendo de ellos
entonces pensemos una vez que este país
esté conectado al cien por cien que
tengamos una velocidad de descarga y de
subida 100% que va a pasar qué vamos a
hacer con la educación y con los
profesores digamos de los colegios
públicos porque por más que el gobierno
está invirtiendo en la educación aquí
hay un problema de que vamos a hacer con
esos niños y qué es lo que están viendo
entonces abrimos las tecnologías
estamos abriendo las carreteras
tecnológicas pero para ver que eso va a
tener una incidencia en lo cultural en
lo social y en lo económico porque esos
niños
vamos a ver digamos sobre aquí me salto
otra vez perdón y es esta transformación
de todos los medios
condenadas saben ustedes que es condenas
me imagino en la mayoría es una de las
principales editoriales ellos tienen la
mayor la mayor parte de publicaciones de
eeuu tienen sede en nueva york ahí está
bueno esa the new yorker están todos es
una empresa que ha venido teniendo
grandes pérdidas el nuevo presidente de
condenadas es un agente es una persona
que no viene del mundo editorial sino
que viene del mundo de la televisión y
de la tecnología ahí es cuando empezamos
a hablar justamente de cambios de
reactivos de que ya no es solamente algo
editorial sino que se convierte en y con
respecto a lo que decía maría ahora se
convierte en un contenido bastante
audiovisual y que mezcla la convergencia
porque entonces es escritura animaciones
etcétera es
hace una semana estuvo una persona que
ya no me acuerdo el nombre de una
canadiense en la cumbre de naranja en
medellín
esa persona decía que el 90% de datos
que se cree el 90% de datos se crearon
en los últimos dos años la mayoría de
empresas solamente se utilizan el 12% de
datos disponibles obviamente los
algoritmos están decidiendo por nosotros
si bien youtube en un comienzo se
convirtió en una plataforma para los
nuevos creadores si ustedes han visto
cómo van cambiando los algoritmos ya no
es lo mismo ya lo están surgiendo esos
mismos creadores y es youtube quién está
marcando y el que está diciendo cuáles
son esos creadores y qué es lo que
tienen que hacer antes digamos que de
alguna manera tenían libertad hoy en día
ellos se ven obligados a producir
continuamente a estar produciendo
continuamente no necesariamente un
contenido de calidad el algoritmo lo que
les está pidiendo es que produzcan
inmediatamente aquella persona que
produzca digamos menos contenidos y sean
de calidad no
por ver en youtube entonces el problema
es ese digamos es que cada vez más es
cogiendo más fuerza las plataformas no
miremos la fotografía del momento porque
es que cuando miramos las encuestas
estamos viendo digamos si vemos ibope es
el padre de familia o que entere el
control pero eso no es la verdad porque
a la par hay una familia que está
conectada que puede estar teniendo un
celular un computador y que está viendo
otro contenido entonces generalmente nos
vamos por esos números digamos que están
viendo cuando es mentira y vuelvo
insisto mirémonos en cinco años miremos
en diez años cuando todo este país esté
conectado qué es lo que van a estar
viendo ahora si ustedes hacen las
encuestas seguramente se van a
sorprender de lo que están viendo
obviamente todo el mundo me va a decir
este es un círculo muy pequeño pero
insisto qué va a pasar en unos años hace
hace un par de semanas a mí medida con
un sobrino y yo le preguntaba max que
estás bien aquí tenemos saber veía un
par de youtubers un mexicano y un
ecuatoriano
yo empecé a ver los contenidos que él
estaba
el escucho digamos que yo estaba viendo
esos contenidos porque lo está viendo en
el computador y lo primero que me dice
es tío no me mires y yo pero como que no
me mires que pasó tú estás viendo unos
contenidos que tú no estás viendo algo
que tú no ves y yo pero si está en la
web es libre qué pasa miren la
transformación y lo complicado de esto y
es que se convierte antes los niños uno
tenía el control porque sabíamos que
estaba bien que estaban viendo por
televisión ahora ellos ese es un mundo
privado entonces el celular el
computador se convierte en su mundo
privado entonces digamos que eso es
digamos muy diciente y de alguna manera
grave porque entonces quien está
teniendo el control entonces volvemos a
lo mismo de la gravedad de que sean
netflix quien esté determinando lo que
nosotros vemos porque podemos decir si
podemos abrir un espacio para que haya
contenido colombiano pero al final es la
empresa la que va a decir qué es lo que
produce y cómo lo ven ahora yo les
explicaba retina latina que es una
plataforma gratuita del cine
latinoamericano surge por una necesidad
de que no había distrito
la exhibición del cine colombiano y
latinoamericano el problema es que hoy
en día esas grandes plataformas que
inteligentemente producen contenido
global también local y están comprando
ya las películas latinoamericanas
películas como el piedra colombiana como
la de power power virus tropical están
empezando a verse en diferentes
plataformas nosotros cómo podemos
competir no tenemos el dinero que tienen
ellos para competir entonces digan de
alguna manera hollywood hoy en día ha
dominado el mercado del cine mundial
porque si bien en colombia tenían una
ley de cine que viene del 2003 y
producíamos dos o tres películas antes
ahora estamos produciendo 40 películas
los números de las audiencias están
viniendo para abajo y eso mismo está
sucediendo en méxico en españa y en
todas partes mi temor es que nuevamente
eso empieza a ocurrir digamos a nivel a
todo nivel
a nivel de la web a nivel de la
televisión etc
qué es lo que nos queda a mí para el
nuestro reto realmente son los temas de
identidad
nosotros no tenemos cómo competir con el
pop de los eeuu con hollywood sino que
son los elementos de identidad creo que
la música de alguna manera ha logrado
reinventarse y ha logrado sobrevivir no
hablo solamente de los reguetoneros
hablemos de hecho quitado un hablemos de
bomba estéreo que recogen sonidos
tradicionales digamos y se han vuelto
también contenidos globales yo creo que
la música tiene un gran sol es un gran
ejemplo para nosotros hay todo hay otro
primero y la automatización del que
vamos a hacer con la automatización del
trabajo lo único que nos es la
creatividad y de dónde viene también la
creatividad es de las artes porque
pensamos que la danza la pintura
etcétera etcétera son digamos materias
aleatorias o que son
digamos adicionales y resulta que no la
danza de alguna manera nos enseña a
movernos en nuestro espacio la música
digamos es también le da uno u otro tipo
de concepción y de digamos de lo que
tiene que ver con la memoria con nuestra
organización y siempre nos enfocamos
solamente en las matemáticas es la
creatividad para mí y las artes lo que
nos da la posibilidad de ser un poco más
competitivos
otro tema importantísimo es las patentes
y la propiedad intelectual no estamos
acostumbrados no sabemos cómo crear
propiedades intelectuales que es lo que
generalmente hacen los eeuu entonces
aquí tiene que ver también con los temas
que se han hablado anteriormente con un
tema de regulación que sí es muy
importante los temas de identidad o de
identidad es porque ya no hablamos
solamente de una identidad general
hablamos también de una cultura afro de
una cultura indígena que ojo porque
además otra cosa que ha ocurrido en el
mundo es que hollywood era o de alguna
manera la televisiones que creaban los
estereotipos cuando hemos visto en la
televisión colombiana
un ejecutivo negro de clase alta
generalmente los negros son considerados
digamos una persona que viene abajo
el músico o el deportista y que luego
superó cuando vemos una persona un par
de personas lgtb besándose en la
pantalla
digamos que todos estos son temas
importantes que en europa se empiezan a
dar estas discusiones porque hay un
público
hollywood generalmente no
tuvo en cuenta las digamos estas
minorías afro indígenas saben ustedes
que el año pasado fue la primera vez que
una mujer le dieron a una mujer le
dieron una película de alto presupuesto
saben qué película fue
la mujer maravilla pero era la primera
vez que hollywood le daba una película
de alto presupuesto a una mujer lo mismo
la cultura el tema de lo negro que fue
pantera negra fue muy importante y era
la primera vez que una película de gran
presupuesto tenía actores afro entonces
todo el tema digamos de cine o de la
televisión es muy importante en la
representatividad como como se está
viendo la gente cómo podemos generar más
contenidos que vayan no solamente hacia
lo afro sino a los discapacitados cuánta
gente cuántas veces vemos contenidos con
discapacitados y ahí hay un público y
ahí es donde hollywood el año pasado
cuando en el flick se empieza a ser
contenido para estas minorías de repente
yo digo empieza a decir ah perdón estilo
negro también hace dinero y es que lo
indígena también puede tener se puede
tener un dinero el tema digamos de
soberanía cultural lo que les decía no
podemos permitir lo que pasó en
hollywood cuando se estrenó los rangers
en el brasil el 90 siendo un país tan
grande el 90% de los estados
ocupado por los jóvenes entonces es como
de verdad me damos prioridad a todos
nuestros temas de identidad cultural la
creación estamos en un momento en que
nos tenemos que reinventar desde cero
diría yo volver a empezar y la
co-creación necesita miradas
interdisciplinarios necesitamos al
publicista al antropólogo a la sociólogo
al ingeniero creando contenidos este es
uno de los términos más importantes en
la co-creación el otro tema es la
innovación constante estamos en un
momento que no sabemos qué va a pasar y
tenemos que estar moviéndonos
continuamente a los nuevos medios que
tienen que ver con lo que ya se ha
hablado anteriormente en ese espacio y
es justamente la realidad virtual y la
realidad aumentada que no sabemos muy
bien para dónde va pero sí creo que hay
que hacer unas apuestas por todos estos
nuevos temas y por estar innovando
continuamente yo creo que hay algo muy
interesante ahora y es hay una cantidad
de incentivos que se están empezando a
crear
lo que les decía tenemos que empezar de
cero y es cómo podemos aprovechar de
esos incentivos que tienen que ver con
incentivos fiscales
con digamos otro otro tipo de
experiencias ahora viene la 1550 y se la
ley 15 56 que ha promovido el digamos
los rodajes internacionales de películas
y yo creo que eso sí bien no está
apoyando propiamente directamente la
creación va a tener unas consecuencias a
la nuestra pero yo sí creo que hay una
transmisión de conocimiento y están
generando trabajo indiscutiblemente
todas las series internacionales para
unos claro pero de todas maneras ojo
porque la televisión nacional está
atrayendo digamos está produciendo menos
está produciendo mucho reality es una
realidad y yo sí creo que digamos es un
real es un reality entes de alguna
manera si tenemos que empezar
a traer más producciones sin perder la
vista de que necesitamos crear nuestros
propios contenidos y generar propiedades
intelectuales pero si es un momento de
unirnos ahora maría del de semana decía
yo sí creo que tenemos que ver como los
medios nacionales la televisión nacional
el cine nacional nos empezamos a juntar
y empezamos a experimentar porque de lo
contrario son estas grandes plataformas
los que van a estar dominando nuestro
mercado y tenemos que ver qué hacer y
cómo competir
[Aplausos]